يفضل الاب وابنه عدم الكشف عن وجهيهما
ولكن الاب يقول ان هذه العائله كاي عائله
امريكيه اخرى وما قالته المعلمه في
سيمارون ميموريال سبارتانز لابنه لم يكن
لائقا قال لي ان المعلمه قالت لي ان هذه
امريكا واذا كنت لا تستطيع الوقوف خلال
تعهد الولاء الوطني في صفي يمكنك الرجوع
الى العراق كانت طالب مصابا خلال لعبه
المصارعه ويقول انه لم يستطع الوقوف بسبب
الالم وكانت المعلمه على علم
باصابته ويضيف انه كان مرتبكا ولم يتوقع
من المعلمه ان تقول شيئا كهذا الغريب في
الامر ان هذا الطالب لم يكن الوحيد الجالس
من بين التلاميذ وهذه كانت المره الوحيده
التي تقول المعلمه فيها شيئا عن عدم
الوقوف واما الاب وابنه فهما مقتنع انها
حركه
عنصريه معتقداتنا الاسلاميه ليس لها علاقه
بوطنيتنا ويضيف ان ما قالته المعلمه لا
يطابق كلام ابنه وقام احد الطلاب بكتابه
رساله قال فيها شعرت بالمه لقد اهانني
الامر لاحظت انها لقبته بارهاب كنت غاضبا
لما قالت وتقول مدرسه حي مقاطعه كلارك في
بيان ان المقاطعه ست تتخذ الاجراءات
الاداريه المناسبه